ten jury offices one of our finest
actors and I think the performing bug
bit early on because I know you know
this picture it's you I don't know how
old you were but you clearly you are the
star of this show here they are taking
her socks off to upstage the others
she looks so unimpressed that girl on
the right is Angela Beresford and she
couldn't stand the Middle's of
sandwiches I can't eat this and I can't
take that and that and that but should
we need the bread she had the bread okay
you should make her a bread sandwich who
just didn't get the memo about the
costume at all we've also got a picture
of you as a young performer in this but
you are quite young
I got turns a lot you clearly did I also
discovered Sonnen which you know it's
supposed to make your hair blonde but
when you have brown hair it turns it red
great was this around the time that you
decided to pass yourself off as a
musician yeah I my dad played the guitar
and I would take the guitar out of the
case and I look around my neighborhood
with the case because I wanted people to
think that it's like walk and just like
look at people me like oh you know and I
would just carry it around so
embarrassing I remember putting thinking
to myself I should probably put vitamins
in there like Flintstone vitamins the
guitar case I know yeah thinking ahead
yes now we have a picture of Jamie Foxx
young yeah but now how what age are you
here
[Applause]
we got the same kind of hair that's
that's a jheri curl right there I was 18
right there that was a backdrop to make
it look like there's brick back there no
I think that's real this picture now if
you thought Jamie Foxx looked old there
I think you were about
[Applause]
I don't I see no problem are you about
20 years old there yeah what's going on
in your head I wanted to look like
magnum p.i I actually grew a mustache in
high school because I played lacrosse
and I thought it would make me look more
threatening didn't really it just made
me look like a porn star using the other
side of the pool
[Music]
you